this next one this was not the sexiest
thing to come out of the interview but I
have a feeling this one had Trump's
lawyers just ripping the hair out of
their head because Megan asked him about
this is related to the federal case that
Jack Smith is bringing Megan asked him
about did he potentially wave around a
classified document to some people that
did not have clearance on that and and
listen to this I did absolutely nothing
wrong okay but let's get to my question
why would you be holding up a newspaper
saying this is still secret I'd have to
look at that classified if I were
president I would have to look at it but
that's right well I could have did you
told Brett Bear that that was
interesting Declassified no I also told
Brett Barris I remember I don't know it
was a long time interview will you tell
me what were you waiting around I also
told Brett Bear that it wasn't a
classified document what were you waving
around in that meeting because it
certainly I'm not going to talk to you
about that because that's already been I
think very substantiated and there's no
problem with it been substantiated there
Jack Smith says let me just tell you you
told Brett let me tell you here we go
again
I'm covered by the presidential records
act I'm allowed to do what I want to do
I'm allowed to have documents the
presidential records Act is civil not
criminal in any way it's civil and I'm
covered by it 100 and this shouldn't
even be a case no and I it should be I'm
trying to combat you criminally I'm
trying to say yes you are but listen No
No it should be Megan let me just not
about the criminal this should be a case
for Biden because he is not covered by
the presidential records Act all right
first off I just want to say as I've
said a million times on this show I
think that all of these cases going
after him are purely politicized and we
only do it to one side and all of that
stuff but in essence he's on audio
saying I'm not supposed to show you this
then he kind of claimed it was a
newspaper but apparently it was these
Iran attack plans and whether he's
allowed to declassify them or not or
show them to people or not it just seems
to me in the midst of all of this you
kinda Josh as a lawyer you kind of don't
go on an interview and and just not be
prepared to answer that honestly
a bit more talk about it at all I
suppose right I I remember earlier this
summer when that first Jack Smith and
Diamond pertaining to the Mar-A-Lago
classified documents when that came out
I was reading through the fact pattern
like we all were and when we got to this
particular anecdote that Megan's asking
him about here which happened at his
Bedminster New Jersey golf club and he's
literally allegedly kind of
waving around these secretive Pentagon
kind of contingency Invader Ron bomaran
plant I mean my very first thought was
like is this Peter Griffin in Family Guy
I mean I I I mean well he says doesn't
he say almost verbatim he says I'm not
supposed to show these to you that might
be the exact quote right and to Megan's
point and again to Carol's Point none of
this is unfair these are extraordinarily
legitimate questions for her for her to
ask even if you unclassified it even if
the presidential Records app the Civil
statue not the criminal statute applies
which is a legally debatable proposition
I think he might be right but it doesn't
really matter because even if all of
that is legally correct why why still do
it like why do you have these documents
in the first place I mean none of this
ultimately makes sense there and also
you know from a criminal defense
perspective here I mean how his lawyers
have not gotten him to shut up and stop
talking about this in front of the
cameras is absolutely mind-blowing and
it also shows why many kind of top tier
lawyers frankly Criminal Spencer has won
absolutely nothing to do with Donald
Trump as their client because he is
probably one of the most horrible
clients to manage ever I mean no one's
going to get near him
Carol let's try to give the devil a zoo
here I mean he he does he hasn't ended
up in jail yet he usually beats the raps
he beats impeachments like does he maybe
just know something about all this how
the game is played that we don't know
well it's kind of early to say he beats
um you know these reps um I think a lot
of it is ridiculous I think we all agree
on that and and none of these really
should be indictments but the fact that
they potentially have him on audio
saying like you shouldn't see this but
here it is
um is a problem and because we could all
kind of Imagine Trump actually doing
that I think in his head he has a you're
for me or against me kind of way of
thinking and we see this among his
supporters also you have to be all in or
all out you can't kind of be nuanced on
Donald Trump and that's why I think he
ends up getting so mad at Megyn Kelly
because in his head he was going into a
friendlier interview because she does
genuinely like him you could tell that
she does she's very warm about him she
she said that you know months and months
and months ago that he is unbeatable in
the primary
um so she said it to me the viral clip
is her talking to me right right so you
know I I think that that's the that's
what's so interesting thing here is and
that's why he gets so angry and why he
says yes you are coming at me criminally
which you know I'm not really sure what
that means but I think that he sees you
know the the liberal media as anti-trump
but that Megan should have been for him
but you need to be able to answer basic
questions and I don't think anything
should excuse that